thank you thank you congratulations get
it oh my God I'm no longer pregnant
thank you God we're here two babies the
show and the sweet Matilda Valley new
I'm telling you here's the thing Eight
Episodes is not enough my friend what do
we have to do for season two there's so
much more stories we're ready I'm
totally ready to dive in for a season
two I Had the Time of My Life on this
show with the best people it couldn't
have been more fun
um I just hope I'm not pregnant next
season again that's all but you know
whatever could be whatever I do hear
that sweet Matilda was quite the kicker
during some of your scenes fests she we
literally we would go to playback to see
if we could see it because it was so
intense I was like how did you not see
that yeah very loud and very you could
see it like in person it was crazy she's
gonna get her sag after card already
immediately
oh I know she really should get credited
in this she was definitely taking over
everyone at this point what does Tom
think of you in this role and then also
just seeing your belly again no I wish
she was here you know he loves this show
I don't know if he's biased because he
like really likes me but we watched all
the episodes and he was like are there
more he wanted more like he's like it's
so much fun so he loved it I know that
always makes you feel good when your
partner's like yes yes yes first
Father's Day plans for him what's on the
car I have a couple little surprises for
him yeah I have a couple little
surprises I'm very excited about it
cannot talk about no because if he can
we watch E.T no we can't last but not
least I wanted you to know we've been
thinking of you and praying for you I
know you're sweet dumpy
means so much
dumby was an E.T star no really look at
her sweet stuff no I remember this no I
remember
there we go
the background stop how are you guys
doing you know what this is the hard
thing about rescuing dogs like this is
what you risk you get we're like why do
we keep doing this when they know we
know they're gonna break our hearts
right but that's why we do it and we do
it over and over and over again and he
was such a blessing in our lives and
everyone that met him was I mean you're
never going to meet another dump truck
so there's a lot of memories there he
was so lucky to have you all as his
family